a US Navy destroyer shot down three
cruise missiles and several drones
launched from the Iran backed jihadis in
Yemen and so finally President Biden
addressed the nation last night as the
nation sleepwalks toward World War III
here's what he had to say if Putin
attacks a NATO Ally we will defend every
inch of NATO which it treaty requires
and calls for we'll have something that
we do not seek make it clear we do not
seek we do not seek to have American
troops fighting in Russia or fighting
against Russia and what and and and
what's there one
and one and
if not exactly encouraging but while
Biden was demanding more money and
weapons for Ukraine and Israel without
any particularly strategic Vision he did
manage to focus on an underd discussed
aspect of the new war in the Middle East
and that of course is the islamophobic
backlash and I know many of you in the
Muslim American Community the Arab
American Community the Palestinian
American community and so many others
are outraged and harded saying to
yourselves here we go again with
islamophobia and distrust we saw after
9/11 here we go again if Joe Biden's
sentiment sounded familiar that's
because it has been uttered before as
part of a famous bit by the late great
comedian nor McDonald well I can't say
my friend's name but he said his biggest
fear
is that Isis or some uh terrorist group
like that would get a hold of a dirty
bomb and exploded over a major city
within the United States mhm and kill
tens of millions of
people because
then the blowback against innocent
Muslims would be absolutely terrible MH
yeah that's right that's true okay let's
do some
jokes there it is I know tonight we're
going to World War III and was Wars and
we're deploying and I know that there
was a horrible terrorist attack in
Israel killed thousand civilians but the
real issue is the
potential for
islamophobia come on Jack when Norm said
it it was a joke when Joe Biden said it
he was a joke and I am Michael nolles
and this is the Michael nolles
[Music]
Show
welcome back to the show this episode's
brought to you by good ranchers my
freezer is so full of good ranchers
right now and my neighbors freezer is
full of good ranchers cuz I ran out of
room and good ranchers this month sent
me pumpkin spice bacon we'll get to all
of it in a second get great me in the
secure price 30 bucks off your order
with code NES goodranchers.com use code
nlls
today de fake porn is spreading
everywhere we're not going to show you
the porn but we are going to go into it
in just a moment first though before we
move off of Joe Biden's completely
disastrous policy in World War III uh he
he also managed to dox some of the most
lethal and important soldiers that we
have fighting for us uh the White House
met with us special forces in Israel oh
yeah by the way we already have troops
on the ground in Israel I know a lot of
people don't know that a lot of people
are saying we shouldn't get involved we
listen we got to stop before the US gets
involved here we're already very
involved we've
got a lot of navy ships over there
aircraft carriers we've got a destroyer
that ended up firing on three missiles
that seem to be heading for Israel and
fired on a bunch of drones that may have
been hovering over the the US Navy
destroyer were in it and we've got
Special Forces on the ground and to put
the cherry on top Joe Biden is doxing
the US Special Forces so he posted on
Instagram this on the White House
Instagram Joe Biden shaking hands with a
bunch of Delta Force I guess says in
Israel President Biden met with First
Responders to thank them for their
bravery and work they're doing in
response to the Hamas terrorist attacks
the White House deleted this rather
quickly because they they realized that
the the P the pictures showed the faces
of these troops and showed some of their
tattoos we've posted a version where the
faces and the tattoos are blurred out
White House then said as soon as this
was brought to our attention we
immediately deleted the photo we regret
the error and any issues this may have
caused issues such as maybe the end of
their military careers issues such as
maybe the targeting of them and their
families by Hamas terrorists who and and
all sorts of terrorists around the world
and all sorts of other foreign
adversaries even State adversaries who
now have the identities of some of our
most important military
assets I don't think Joe Biden did this
on purpose I be shocked if he did this
on
purpose he did it out of incompetence
his administration did this out of
incompetence the social media team the
photographers who took the pictures the
people who posted this the spokesman who
made excuses for this it's just so
incompetent it's so careless and this is
the way Joe Biden operates this is the
way the liberal establishment broadly
operates and and
carelessness when taken to this kind of
extreme
is downright
criminal how much can go wrong in three
years 21 22 23 Less Than 3
years the
economy in chaos inflation through the
roof first major war in Europe since
World War II war breaking out in the
Middle East that is already involving
the United States and Lebanon and Syria
Syria and Iran and Yemen and World War
II how many things can go wrong in such
a short period of Time When Donald Trump
was President things were good and then
coid happened and we locked the country
down and they rigged the election and
now we've got this guy who doesn't know
what his name is who can't even speak
when he's addressing the nation on the
prospect of World War II and the world
is being thrown into chaos and is it
because they're evil I yeah in some ways
they are evil they advocate for very
evil things like killing lots of babies
and destroying the family and backing
some of our enemies sometimes and sure
but a lot of the time they're just so
negligent and careless that the world
goes up and smoke and they say huh I
don't know what do I can't even speak
what I it's not my fault but it it is
this degree of negligence from all of
these people at the top
is downright
criminal things were going very well and
they to quote Barack Obama never
underestimate Joe Biden's ability to F
things up speaking of incompetence
there's a waitress who's gone viral on
Tik Tok for complaining that she doesn't
make
$200,000 a year despite the fact that
she has a bachelor's degree in Business
Marketing I have a bone to pick with
America so I'm headed to my serving
job I hate it
I hate it why I make more money serving
I have my literal business marketing
degree that put me in a
cute $80,000 in
debt and I make more serving Sushi roles
cuz I was I've been applying to
marketing jobs for weeks now and the the
pay cut is
insane insane but the jobs that are like
a cute 150 to 200,000 a year I'm not
getting those I'm a 20 almost
25-year-old old my birthday soon almost
25-year-old chick going against you know
corporate ass America people was so much
experience all I got is my degree you
know people say get your degree but then
they don't talk about how you need
experience the degree was the
experience I need to relax
the degree was not the experience I I
pity her I I don't pity the extreme
entitlement this woman is saying hey I'm
a 25-year-old chick I don't have any
experience really in anything and I need
to make $200,000 a year because I got
some almost certainly meaningless degree
and I took out some debt and I made poor
financial decisions and but the culture
encouraged me to make those poor
financial decisions but I'm 25 years old
and I want to make 200 Grand did you
make 200 Grand at 25 years old did you
if you're listening to this show right
now have you made 200 Grand ever have
the vast majority of people ever made
$200,000 let alone at
what planet is this woman living on
where she thinks that is something that
I suppose that's something to shoot for
later on in your career if you're
willing to put in some hard work it but
where you think you're just entitled to
200 that's a lot of money and you're 25
no 25 unless you're working on Wall
Street or in a handful of very very high
paying jobs no 25-year-old makes that
and she makes an observation here that
she thinks is an indictment of our
economic system but it's not actually
she she is ironically undermining her
point when she says I can make more
money waiting tables than I can pursuing
my career we'll get to that in one
second cuz we do have to talk about that
but first when you want to talk to your
friends you need to check out peer talk
right now go to peer talk.com last week
peer talk announced they would alleviate
$10 million in veteran debt by Veterans
Day how by giving a portion of every new
order to this cause thanks to your
support P talk is 27% to their goal with
three weeks to go our veterans gave
everything to protect our great nation P
talk understands the sacrifices they
have made when you switch to peer talks
Lightning Fast 5G Network they will
donate a portion of every new order to
this noble cause you can make a real
difference just by choosing Superior
cell phone service P talks plans start
at just 20 bucks a month offering
unlimited talk text more data and a
mobile hotspot just go to Pur talk.com
NCW and make the switch let's rally
together show our unwavering support for
our veterans and also support this
excellent company which is going to give
you the best cell phone service out
there at a fraction of the price Pur
talk.com ncwl switch to Pur talk today
it is the right move it is the American
way peer talk.com
slns she can make more money waiting
tables that's true you you can make
relatively decent money waiting tables
have waited tables probably many of you
who are listening to this right now have
waited tables you
can the downside of waiting tables is
there's not necessarily a ton of job
growth there can be if you really want
to dig into the restaurant business and
then I don't know become a head waiter
become a manager who knows open a
restaurant like there there are paths
for growth but generally speaking if you
are just going to be a waiter then you
can make relatively decent money
depending on the restaurant depending on
the clients but there's going to be a
ceiling there this woman wants to blow
past that ceiling she wants to make
$200,000 a year but if you want to make
$200,000 a year you got to do a lot of
grunt work first before you can get on
that path you don't get some of the
benefits of just having a job if you
want to have this
more risky and ambitious kind of
career in my first jobs in politics my
very first job in politics I made I did
the math I I received a monthly stipend
I was a teenager I made 75 cents an hour
that was my first job it was a campaign
job in politics and then one time while
working for the campaign I got a
speeding ticket for 300 bucks so that
reduced my earnings to like 50 cents an
hour
I think about my first jobs in the media
I'm sure I wasn't paid anything and even
when I was paid something it was very
Hit or
Miss if you if you want to have a career
one of these things that's a little
tougher to find and that involves more
risk you're going to have to do a lot of
grunt work now the the mistake here is
this woman went way into debt to get a
degree that is meaningless no
undergraduate Business Degree in my
estimation is worth $80,000 because it's
not experienced and the employers don't
view that as experience and you're going
to learn a lot more with on the job
training I'm I'm a the last conservative
I think one of the last conservatives
who promotes University education but
only in certain circumstances at certain
universities and specifically if you're
studying something that will not
directly get you a job I think the point
of it is to study Dusty old books and to
read old philosophers and Poets and
historians
you can do that better at a university
than you can other places on your own on
YouTube sitting around in a bull session
somewhere universities are still in some
ways better at doing that than other
places no University is better at
teaching you business marketing than a
company is a company is always going to
be better at that and This Woman's just
been duped and so she's 50 she's 80
grand in the whole and she's been fed
pack of lies that if she goes to
Palookaville University and gives them a
bunch of money she'll get some piece of
paper that's going to give her a
bazillion dollars and that's just not
true but if she is ambitious if she's
really ambitious then she will give up
the waitering job and she will accept
the lower pay in the short term for
bigger payoffs in the long term this is
the political issue here and you see it
at the personal level and you see it at
the political we as a country used to be
willing to defer gratification you think
of the pilgrims who came over here in
1620 they deferred comfort for their
whole lives they really never had any
and they just worked very hard with that
Pilgrim Puritan work ethic and over time
they built up a prosperous country and
now we get to enjoy the fruits of that
and we hope that we can pass that on to
our
children I don't think we think that way
anymore we just want the short-term
profit we want the quick money we don't
think about the future we don't have
children and when we do have children
The Inheritance that we leave them is
mountain of debt speaking of trying to
get jobs Jim Jordan is back in it I was
dismayed yesterday I was crestfallen
because Jim Jordan seemed to signal that
he was pulling out of the speaker race
and they were going to do some complete
nonsense where they were going to
empower the temporary default speaker
with some extra power to so basically
the Republicans would be giving up their
speakership and then Jim came back and
he said I'm not dropping out I will just
say this we made the we made the pitch
to uh
members on the resolution as a way to
lower the temperature and get back to
work uh we decided that wasn't where
we're going to go I'm still running for
speaker and I plan to go to the floor uh
and get the votes and win this race but
I want to go talk with a few of my
colleagues particular I want to talk
with the 20 individuals who voted
against me um so that we can move
forward and begin to work for the
American people my man that's great
there is not a single chance that
conservatives will ever get a better
speaker candidate in the near future Jim
Jordan is Rock Solid compared to the
speaker candidates that we've had
basically for my entire lifetime uh so
we got to make it happen and the great
thing about Jordan is he's not just some
rock ribbed bomb throwing conservative
who appeals to the far right but doesn't
appeal to anyone else he's a very
measured serious sensible reasonable guy
he can work with his colleagues he's not
one of these uh coup d'a plotters who
voted to OU McCarthy he's he's in some
ways a party guy he goes along with he a
team player but he is also a man of
conviction and he is by far the most
conservative speaker candidate we've had
in my lifetime there are these 20
holdouts here these squishes these
liberals these jerks uh I I hope I I
suspect that Jim will not refer to them
in those terms that I'm referring to
them in he'll probably work with them I
hope he prize away those votes the
speaker vote is scheduled for this
morning so this could change in real
time uh but whatever happens on that
speaker vote I hope he sticks it out
he's a good candidate and there's not a
chance Republicans are going to get a
better candidate so the only alternative
then even if you're a squish moderate
liberal whatever is the alternative is
you just have a fake default speaker
without any power which means you've
just empowered the Democrats which means
they have a effectively control of the
whole government which is maybe what
some of these Liberal Republicans want
this is these Liberal Republicans a lot
of them up in New York that's probably
what they
want and candidates who are looking to
primary them should keep that in
mind speaking of the House of
Representatives I just want to touch on
this briefly because you probably
haven't seen very much of it in the news
but yesterday at the US capital there
was
an in
Insurrection that was an the worst it
was the worst day ever in the history of
the capital except according to the
mainstream media and except according to
the Democrats and ex they're going to
block out those pictures what happened
yesterday there W I'm I'm using this
mocking term Insurrection because that's
the way that we talk about January 6 but
what happened yesterday was much worse
than January 6 you had a bunch of pro
Hamas leftists who marched all through
the capitol complex interrupting
official Congressional proceedings as
bad or worse than whatever happened
on January 6th the very worst day a
sacred democracy has never
recovered and they'll face no
consequences whatsoever you didn't even
hear about it if you heard about it you
heard about it from me or a handful of
other conservatives but there they are
people defending a terrorist
organization Hamas
chanting uh yelling screaming and
official proceedings busting in while
members are trying to speak and conduct
their
business no consequences at all I don't
mention this to suggest that we should
arrest all these people I mean we could
that'd be fine I guess to give them a
taste of their own medicine I mention it
to remind
you that one January 6th was not even
anywhere close to resembling what the
Liberals told you it was but two to show
you the power of the media because for
people who are not listening to this
show who don't pay very close attention
to politics they've just got this image
seared into their mind that there was
this
attempted armed Insurrection that took
place on January 6 2021 we almost lost
our government this Temple of democracy
almost came crumbling down but
thankfully Nancy Pelosi and the good
guys won after the insurrectionists
murdered dozens of cops and almost
killed AOC or whatever none of none of
that happened none of that what happened
yesterday by the Liberals was as bad or
worse and you never heard it because of
the power of the media and especially
now as we're hurdling toward World War
III keep that in mind when you're seeing
actual War propaganda coming out from I
can't even say both sides from all sides
because there are multiple conflicts
here don't let your emotions run away
with you don't if you were fooled by
January 6th don't be Fooled Again to
quote a great political philosopher
George W bush fool me once shame on you
fool me twice well uh uh the point is
you're not going to fool me again now
speaking of
ranchers when you want to have good
quality meat you got to check out good
ranchers right now go to
goodranchers.com use code nolles every
Halloween you hear about the dangers in
the candy that your kids will get but
this year the real tricks are in the
meat aisle good ranchers wants to take
the trick out of your meat and they're
throwing in a treat for my listeners for
30 bucks off your order with promo code
NES kwg goodranchers.com I got a new
order of good ranchers yesterday you
know I love good good ranchers it's one
of the least favorite things I have
about going on the road is I have to
miss eating my delicious good ranchers
so I get the steaks and I get the ground
beef and the burgers the greatest ever
and I get the beautiful chicken and
everything and you know what they threw
in pumpkin spice bacon and you know
what's even more amazing about this
Alisa hates flavors added to Meats cuz
she thinks it's usually going to be some
kind of artificial terrible thing that's
going to you know turn the frogs gay or
whatever but the way that they did this
with the pumpkin spice bacon it is so
natural it is so like all of their it's
just the best in the business they got
the lowest prices
it's if if you're not ordering good
ranchers right now I don't know that I
can possibly help you Texas code nolles
kwls for 30 bucks off your box today the
box of America's best meet and seafood
30 bucks off goodranchers.com American
Meat delivered my favorite comment
yesterday is from Ben Peasley 6394 who
says I have expected Michael to mention
the launch of Jeremy's bras and
undergarments during the Victoria Secret
section of today's show Jeremy's negl is
one of our more uh provocative projects
obviously scheduled for 2024 the problem
is Jeremy is still overseas in Hungary
shooting pen Dragon so we haven't had
time to do the photo shoot of him
wearing the negl but once he gets back
uh he we can do the photo shoot uh we
can then post those photos with Jeremy's
bras and undergarments and then we can
all set our eyes and even our Mind's Eye
On Fire so that we can try to try to
forget those images speaking of
Republicans trying to get votes Tim
Scott does not seem to be doing very
well in the presidential race remember
there's a presidential race going on a
lot of people sort of forgot that Tim
Scott's super pack is pulling millions
of dollars from TV ads so New York Times
is reporting that trust in the mission
pack signaled it would cut millions in
TV ads because after millions of dollars
in TV ad buys Tim Scott's numbers have
hardly budged and Rob Collins who's
co-chairman of the Tim Scott super pack
says we aren't going to waste our money
when the electorate isn't focused or
ready for a trump alternative we've done
the research we've studied the focus
groups we've been following Tim on the
trail this electorate is locked up and
money spent on mass media is not going
to change Minds until we get a lot
closer to voting okay so they're they're
saying Tim Scott's still in the race
we're still backing Tim Scott but the TV
ads were running so far uh people like
Trump too much still so we got to wait
for them to like Trump a little bit less
and then then the numbers can start to
budge I don't really think that this
issue is about Tim Scott or Donald Trump
or any of the candidates I think the
reason that it's smart for the Scott
pack to pull the millions out of TV ads
is because tv ads
don't work nearly as well as they used
to because it's 2023 not
1993 tv ads do not matter that much
linear TV so that's cable and network TV
make up less than half of TV viewership
now which doesn't even make what does
that mean it means that when people
watch TV when you sit down on your couch
you are probably you are most likely
watching streaming services Netflix
YouTube
Hulu hopefully daily War plus hopefully
bent key you're not watching cable I
have never personally subscribed to
Cable ever in my entire life I've been
on cable TV many many times that is part
of my job I still have never
subscribed I I don't know maybe any
Millennials who subscribe to TV very
very few if any Zoomer do Zoomers
subscrib to cable TV or Network TV
no also the targeting is just way worse
on TV with with digital ad targeting you
can t you know they they know every
single thing about us every thought that
pops into our head our iPhone somehow
records and then you get the ads
delivered to you so this is a
generational issue and you're seeing it
reflected by the way in the campaigns
Donald Trump I know he's not exactly a
spring chicken though he seems fairly
energetic Donald Trump is running a
campaign that appeals to young voters
much more than say the Pence campaign
much more than say the Tim Scott
campaign or the Nikki haly campaign I
like all three of those people
personally they're very nice
people but it is simply a fact their
campaigns are more appealing toward
Boomers and maybe some of the Gen xers
who appeals to the Millennials and
Zoomers it's Ronda santis it's Donald
Trump it's V ramaswami it's Doug bergham
no maybe not Doug bergham it's those
guys and those are the guys who are
campaigning mostly online and in
inventive ways not on TV speaking of
watching things on screens this is a
story I've been teasing for a couple
days deep fake
porn might finally destroy civilization
you know some say the world will end in
fire some say in ice from what I've
tasted of desire I hold with those who
favor fire but if it had to perish twice
I think I know enough of haate to know
that for Destruction ice is also great
and would
suffice and frankly it's not going to be
F fire or ice it's going to be deep fake
porn
because this is a new article just came
out at from I think
wired deep fake videos are skyrocketing
the the biggest search engines in the
world are funneling a ton of clicks to
these websites they're mostly not for
just fun little jokes it's largely for
porn since all developments on the
internet are driven by porn and the the
Deep fakes apparently there are at least
quar million videos were there about
that have been uploaded to the top 35
websites set up either exclusively or
partially to deep fake porn videos in
the past 7 years according to the
researcher over the first 9 months of
this year 113,000 videos were uploaded
to these websites so these are just like
weird specifically deep fake porn
websites that's not even taking into
account the the major porn websites
which which constitute The Lion's Share
of the
internet the the Deep fake porn issue
has affected celebrities and some
celebrities have sued over this and
they've taken all sorts of legal action
my fear my greater fear for this is it's
going to it probably already is but I I
suspect it's going to affect just
orinary people who don't have a public
profile and who's going to drive it it's
going to be people who are addicted to
porn who's addicted to porn young men I
guess and older men I guess and
increasingly some women and what they're
going to do you you see how mid Journey
works right now you see how chat GPT
works you can put in a very complex
command you know the Pixar movie of
Michael nolles eating a tuna hogi in
timbuk 2 and 60 seconds later you get
this image that looks very
accurate pretty soon it's going to if it
isn't already it's going to be that cute
girl in my math class doing unspeakable
things in whatever sort of setting and
it's going to spit that out too in fact
according to this report it already is
and then what happens that is a form of
I don't think I'm overstating it that's
a form of digital rape you are being
violated to such a degree and yet right
now it seems like there's no real legal
recourse because it's all just kind of
fake so it would be the rudimentary way
of doing this would be if you cut out a
picture of someone's head and you just
pasted it on the picture of another
person's body but it's not even really
another person's body it's it's just a
fake body created by a
computer but it looks as though you are
you are putting this person in a
position that is extremely shameful and
embarrassing and disgraceful so what do
you do about that on the one hand just
as a political matter we're never going
to be able to trust videos and photos
again which maybe is a good thing it'll
reduce some to some degree political
Scandal and allow us to talk more about
issues it's going to severely hamper our
ability to adjudicate important
political questions like War we're not
going to know what we can trust already
in this war you're seeing that issue
because because you're seeing AI
generated images that look
indistinguishable almost from actual
videos of the war and then at the
personal level you're going to see
you're going to see people you're going
to see young people you're going to see
people in high school you're going to
see people in college being violated in
this way so what do you do I we have to
get ahead of this issue just like in the
90s the Republicans and Democrats came
together to try to get ahead of the
internet porn issue until some stupid
liberal judges shot it Down based on an
erroneous reading of the
Constitution we've got to try to get
ahead of this I think you go after after
the Deep fake porn in the same way we go
after prostitution which is that maybe
you try to punish the the customers the
users but ultimately I think you've got
to punish The Pimps and in this case
that means you've got to punish the
hosts you got to punish the people who
are hosting and encouraging this stuff
which means you might have to rewrite
parts of one of those laws from the
1990s the communications decency act to
stop giving so much protection to big
internet companies that Host this kind
of smut but just as you would go after a
pimp for human trafficking I think that
I think you got to go after those
producers because obviously you're not
going to go after the girl you could go
after the consumer but in many cases the
the consumers of this kind of porn are
going to be teenage boys and so what are
you going to do you're going to lock up
a teenage boy for some weird making some
weirdo maybe you will but you're going
to lock up a lot of teenage boys in
America we've got to take a more
proactive stance a from as a political
order and say if you an adult with a
bank account with a business who are
preing on young girls and young men with
this kind of smut if you engage in that
kind of business you go to jail for a
long long time you know there's never
been a better time to become a daily
wire plus member today you can hardly
find a kids show that doesn't inject
some lgbtq lpq l m n o p z XYZ agenda
and we've had enough of it at the daily
wire we don't just complain about the
culture we fight back and build
Alternatives which is why we launched
our new kids company bent key an
entirely new app with new episodes
available every Saturday morning that's
right it is the return of Saturday
morning cartoons it's all 100% adree but
we can't build Alternatives without you
and now with your daily wire plus annual
membership you get access to all the
great content at the daily wire and all
the amazing content at Ben key if you
think that's a fight worth fighting then
join us get your membership now we've
already invested tens of millions of
dollars there's so much more to do stand
with us as we build the future that we
all want to see you can get bent key now
at dailywire.com
subscribe finally finally we've arrived
at my favorite time of the week when I
get to hear from you in the mailbag this
mailbag is sponsored by P talk go to P
talk.com NOS today take it
away hello MK this is Sweet Little Brian
from the village named after a mud
turtle I was curious since you have
fully embraced and vibed and are living
the PSL lifestyle and allowing your
inner white girl to burst out of you I
have become
concerned did all of those herbs and
spices get to your brain and turn you
into a hippie causing you to pick up the
sitar and play the star spangle Banner
for your
outro if that is the case I believe that
for the good of society and especially
for the good of you and the other poor
people who have fallen prey to this
confusion pumpkin spice must be
eradicated from public life entirely the
whole Preposterous hysteria of a
flavoring at every level and since
you're man enough to embrace your inner
16-year-old white girl I will take your
lead and someone's up mine to tell you
like I know you're like on the daily
wire but like you're a daily friend to
me thank you very much I really
appreciate all of the Magnificent
diction in that question but to the
question itself have the pumpkin spices
gone to my head and turned me into a big
hippie it's a fear it's a fear but
you'll notice I was playing The Star
Spangled Banner and when I play sitar in
part because I'm not a good sitar player
but in part because I don't want to
accidentally perform some you know Hindu
liturgies or something uh which is
obviously intimately tied in with Indian
classical music I I tend to play western
music on the sitar that's what I do and
so like
like Christians going in and taking
certain Pagan rituals and traditions and
just baptizing them and claiming them
for ourselves which is something that
has happened much less frequently in
history than is often claimed people say
Oh Christmas is Pagan or Easter is Pagan
or and none of that is really true but
certain little tiny things do come from
Pagan Traditions so too that's what I'm
doing with the Satur we are we're making
satar great again next
question howdy howdy again Mr knows it
is SLA my base coming at you with
another question so I really would like
to know what is your secret to staying
calm and staying happy with all of the
stress and anger that comes with
debating politics and the Liberals
obviously they have a lot of anger so
they're not as level-headed as we are
but sometimes we can get caught up in
the moment we can get angry we can
become irrational but I want to know
what is your secret to staying
level-headed staying calm and being
collective in the face of all of this
stress and stupidity thanks again as
always one secret is just practicing
it's true of any habit it just the more
you do it the easier it becomes to do it
but the other secret is I am a big fan
of Providence I really like Providence I
believe in Providence I believe that God
has an order for the world and there is
a story here that is unfolding with my
cooperation and with the cooperation of
my free will I'm not saying I'm merely a
passive actor here but that God
ultimately is in control of this story
we can know the beginning of the story
we know the middle of the story we know
the end of the story things unfold in a
way that can be uh marvelous and that
are more marvelous than whatever I could
think of there's a good line from
Alexander Pope which is that all nature
is but art unknown to thee all chance
Direction which thou canst not see uh
there's a line my friend Father George
rutler has used which is he says um a
wicked generation seeks signs and
wonders and I'm not the first to say it
but a stupid generation ignores signs
and wonders and so if I'm having a a
rough day things keep happening to me
that are outside of my control and they
inconvenience me or irritate me I will
sometimes get a little bit of a kick out
of it I'll say well this is happening
for some reason it's not mine to know
exactly what that reason is necessarily
and so I will be grateful for whatever
God has given me when I was doing the
interview with Father reill The Exorcist
we kept having audio problems we didn't
think we were going to have any audio
problems we should have gotten a
25-minute run without some clanging
noise outside and yet s minutes in audio
problems I said cut all right we restart
another seven minutes goes by audio
problems cut okay here we go restart
this happens I think about four times I
turned to father rehill I said hey does
this happen to you a lot he says Michael
it's the Story of My Life said oh got it
okay just keep rolling next
time
sort of things that that can happen amid
spiritual warfare and so I I find a
great deal of delight about that uh
there there's something bigger going on
in the story than whatever particular
activity I'm trying to accomplish next
question dear Michael according to
Catholic Doctrine can non-catholic
Christians go to heaven I haven't been
able to find a straightforward answer to
this online thank you so
much I make no pronouncement over who
goes to heaven and who goes to hell
because I do not possess the keys to the
kingdom of heaven and it is not the case
that whatever I bind on Earth will be
bind in heaven and what I loose on Earth
will be loosed in heaven um if you are
baptized uh and you have faith uh that's
good good place to start um but we know
from John that there are certain sins
which are mortal and
so how do we have our sins forgiven our
Lord in the gospel establishes a way he
he breathes on the apostles and he says
receive the Holy Spirit um whose sins
you forgive or forgiven whose sins you
retain or retained and then we see this
through the entire history of the church
so I have many loved ones who are
outside of holy mother Church to varying
degrees and in uh certain cases I
hope intensely pray for God's
extraordinary Mercy but if you want if
you want the what I consider to be a
sure thing I would Avail yourself of the
sacraments that holy mother Church
dispenses how's that for an answer
wouldn't say wouldn't say you're without
hope I would never say that sort of
thing
um and you know Christ being crucified
on the cross he turns to the good thief
and he says today you'll be with me in
Paradise the good thief is not received
formal sacraments Al though you know he
he he received the the true meaning of
the sacrament himself right there on the
cross uh
but if it if it were me I would
recommend availing yourself of all of
the uh opportunities for God's grace
next question hi Michael Arun here I'd
like to get your thoughts on Free Speech
in light of last weekend's attack on
Israel by Hamas because I learned about
it in an odd way over the weekend I saw
some Rumblings of this attack on Twitter
twiter but I figured that this was just
another rocket attack that would likely
be blocked by the Iron Dome which would
minimize casualties and that Israel
would make a proportionate response and
you know then we could we could all go
home uh but I watched Ben Shapiro on
Monday mostly because you were on
vacation and after watching the videos
he had compiled of hamas's attack I only
then realized that Hamas had essentially
perpetrated a holocaust and microcosm I
mean these are by far the worst images
I've ever seen in my life
and the only reason I know about any of
this is because Hamas decided to post
their war crimes on social media now I'm
familiar with the model of free speech
that you've laid out in speechless and
I'm sympathetic to it but the principal
reason that I and many others are aware
of the depths of hamas's depravity and
their anti-Semitism is because the
internet has afforded them the right to
free speech if only accidentally it
seems to me that if people with evil
beliefs wish to talk about those beliefs
it is a good idea for us to grant them
the right to speak freely so that we can
know that they believe these things and
so that we can act accordingly so I'm
curious how do you think that the
principle of free speech applies to evil
and demonic people such as the members
of Hamas thank you as always for your
wisdom aun typically an excellent
question uh and and your observation is
quite right but it cuts both ways which
is Hamas committed these particularly
egregious atrocities in part to upload
it to social media it wasn't the
Israelis it wasn't the westerners who
were uploading these videos at first at
least it was Hamas uploading these
videos because the purpose of terrorism
is to Target civilians to achieve a
political purpose and to scare the hell
out of civilians and in this case
basically to convince the Jews who are
living in the holy land that it would be
smarter for them to live in New York
than to live surrounded by enemies so if
not for social media if not for the
ability to publicize these crimes would
the crimes even have been so
egregious maybe but I think it's
indisputable that Hamas was playing to
the
cameras they implicitly admit that
themselves when they upload all of those
videos so to your point though without
trying to scirt the issue I think that
there can be good uses of making
exceptions to rules of propriety and
standards on social media uh to expose
the barbarity of a particular crime to
achieve a particular political purpose
to shed some light on a significant
historical event absolutely I think
still on Twitter There Are Rules against
snuff films you're not social media
generally you're not allowed to upload a
a regular old snuff film and yet we are
seeing videos of people being killed so
that is technically a snuff film but you
you see that kind of exception already I
would just make those judgment calls as
a matter of prudence I wouldn't make it
as a matter of some firm ideological
principle that we always need to see all
sorts of gruesome videos uh I don't I
don't see what would be achieved by that
and a lot of bad things could could
result as a consequence okay we'll get
to one written mail bag before we get to
the in segmentum and we'll get to more
mailbag there from nashon Hey Sexy Mike
I'm a high schooler oh
no generally the high schoolers should
not use my prop only only the adults
should use my proper title uh I'm a high
schooler taking a class government and
was recently learning about the Iran
Contra Scandal since you're a big
proponent of Reagan I wanted to know
your thoughts on it or if the class is
just teaching me wrong things Iran
Contra was fine the only problem is that
it didn't go far enough Iran Contra was
when the Reagan
Administration it would appear without
the knowledge of the president was
trading arms for hostages in Iran and
then using some of the money from there
was there was an embargo with Iran so
they couldn't legally sell sell the arms
but they were selling arms to Iran
anyway to try to get hostages out of
Iran and then they were taking some of
the money that was made from the arm
sales to fund the contras who were
opposing the Communists in Nicaragua and
I don't really see the issue with it the
the problem was the legal issue there
was that uh there was no money
appropriated to fund the contras in
Nicaragua it was obviously a good thing
to fund the contess in Nicaragua there's
no question about that was the it was
the the right-wingers versus the
Communists and in virtually any of those
circumstances you want to oppose the I
mean Communists are very very evil
people and their ideology is very very
evil and diabolical so that was good we
don't want Communists taking over Latin
America uh there were hostages in Iran
you want to get the hostages back you
don't want to do it in a way that's
going to encourage terrorists to steal
more of your people so they did it
somewhat surreptitiously and the issue
was that they circumvented the legal
means but we continue to do this I mean
that's how we gave Ukraine $6 billion
over the last few months
remember Congress didn't want to
appropriate more funds to the Ukraine
war so the dod just pretended that they
found $6 billion in a couch cushion and
they said no no actually the money was
because the weapons were cheaper than we
thought they were so anyway here's
another $6 billion that was money that
we sent to Ukraine that was not really
appropriated that they just did some
kind of funny math on the books and sent
the weapons over there it's the same
thing as Iran Contra the I guess the
only is there was a clear right and
wrong in the case of what was going on
in Iran Contra and Nicaragua and the
Reagan Administration was on the right
side of things and in the case of the
Biden Administration they have no
strategic vision and often they're
funding people who aren't so great it's
a different that's my view on it so
maybe you were taught correctly you you
might have been taught the facts of it
and then just told it was a bad thing
there was nothing nothing wrong about it
at all it's a shame that that as many
Reagan administration staffers had to
suffer consequences as they did okay
it's fake headline Friday baby the rest
of the show continues now you do not
want to miss it head on over to the the
segment use code n@ checkout daily.com
two months free and all annual
[Music]
plans